Hi, I'm Craig, and this is Crash Course Government
and Politics, and today we're finally, at
long last, moving on from the structures and
branches of government and onto the structures
and branches of trees. This is a nature show
now.
Okay, we're not moving on completely, because
we're still talking about courts, but today
we'll be discussing actual court decisions,
and the kind of things that courts rule on,
rather than how they do it. That's right,
we're moving onto civil rights and civil liberties.
[Theme Music]
Okay, first I want to talk about something
that I find confusing: the difference between
civil rights and civil liberties. Usually in America,
we use the terms interchangeably, which adds
to the confusion, but lawyers and political scientists
draw a distinction, so you should know about it.
Then you can go back to calling civil liberties "rights"
and civil rights "liberties," and most people won't care.
But I'll care. I'll be disappointed in you.
So civil liberties are limitations placed
on the government. Basically, they are things
the government can't do that might interfere
with your personal freedom.
Civil rights are curbs on the power of majorities
to make decisions that would benefit some
at the expense of others. Basically, civil
rights are guarantees of equal citizenship,
and they mean that citizens are protected
from discrimination by majorities.
Take, for example, same sex marriage. You
could think of it as a liberty, except that
not everyone is free to marry at any given
time. Six year olds can't get married, and
you can't marry your sibling.
But same sex marriage is a civil rights issue
because in the states that don't allow it, the
majority of voters is denying something to a minority,
creating inequality in the way that the laws work.
Now, just to make things more confusing, lawyers
often talk about the difference between substantive
and procedural liberties, but they usually
call them rights instead of liberties.
That's a lawyer eagle. A legal eagle.
Substantive liberties are limits on what the
government can do. For example, the first
amendment says that congress shall make no
law establishing religion. So this means that
they cannot create a national church or declare
that Christianity or Islam or Hinduism is
the official religion of the US.
Procedural liberties are limits on how the
government can act. For example, in America
in courtroom dramas, there is a presumption
that someone is innocent until proven guilty.
This presumption means that in criminal cases,
juries and judges have to act as though the
accused is innocent until the prosecution
convinces them otherwise. If they are not
convinced, the accused person doesn't go to
prison.
So now that we understand the difference between
civil rights and civil liberties perfectly
because of my amazing explanation, let's focus
on liberties and try to figure out what they
are and where they come from, with some help
from Thought Bubble.
So civil liberties are contained in the incredibly
unhelpfully named "Bill of Rights," which
isn't even called that in the Constitution.
It's just a name that we give to the first 10 amendments.
The 9th amendment is included to remind us
that the list of liberties and/or rights in
the other amendments isn't exhaustive. There
might be other rights out there, but the constitution
doesn't specifically say what they are. Thanks
constitution.
In some cases, it's pretty clear. The first
amendment, for example, says that "congress
shall make no law respecting the establishment
of religion, or abridging the free exercise
thereof, or abridging the freedom of speech
or of the press to assemble or to infringe
the right to petition the government for redress
of grievances." Pretty straight forward.
But other cases are not so clear.
The second amendment says "the right to keep
and bear arms shall not be infringed," but
it doesn't say by whom. Same thing with the
5th amendment guarantees against self incrimination.
Could congress force you to incriminate yourself?
How would they do that?
And the 8th amendment prohibits cruel and
unusual punishments, like presumably shock
pens, but it doesn't say who is forbidden
from cruelly and unusually punishing. My mom
wasn't forbidden from keeping me from playing
video games.
As usual, we might expect the Supreme Court
to sort out this mess, but initially they
were no help at all. In a case that you've
probably never heard of, called Barron vs.
Baltimore, decided in 1833, the court said
that the Bill of Rights applied to the national,
meaning federal government, not to the states.
They said that every American has dual citizenship,
but not the good kind. They meant you are
a citizen of the US and of the state in which
you reside, and basically that the constitution
only protected you from the federal government.
In other words, if the state of Indiana wanted
to punish me cruelly or unusually, they could.
Thanks, Thought Bubble. So Barron vs. Baltimore
left Americans in a bit of a civil liberties
pickle, and not the good kind of pickle.
They were protected from the national government
doing terrible things, like quartering troops
in their homes, but not from the state doing
the same thing.
And since the state was close to home and
the national government was far away and,
compared with today, tiny and weak, these
protections were pretty weaksauce, so what
happened to change this? I hope something,
because I like a zesty government sauce.
The 14th amendment & the Supreme Court happened.
After the Civil War, as part of the reconstruction,
the 13th, 14th, and 15th amendments were added
to the constitution. Of these, the 14th is
the most important, probably the most important
of all amendments. What does it say?
Well the first section, which is the one that
really matters, and I'm not going to read
the whole thing okay? It reads "all persons
born or naturalized in the United States and
subject to the jurisdiction thereof, are citizens
of the United States and of the state wherein
they reside. No state shall make or enforce
any law which shall abridge the privileges
or immunities of citizens of the United States.
Nor shall any state deprive any person of
life, liberty, or property, without due process
of law; nor deny any person within its jurisdiction
the equal protection of the laws."
What this means is that the federal government's
like: "Listen states, you can't be dumb. Just
stop it. Okay? We're all in this together.
Alright?" It means states can't deny equal
protection, civil rights, or due process,
which in this case encompasses civil liberties.
This in theory makes it impossible for states
to infringe upon the liberties and the Bill of Rights.
But the legal system being what it is, it's
not quite that simple. Did you think it'd
be simple? The Supreme Court could have just
ruled that all the rights and liberties in
the Bill of Rights applied to the states,
which seems to be what the 14th amendment
implies, but they didn't. Instead they ruled
that each of the rights or liberties had to
be incorporated against the states on a case-by-case
basis.
This is a concept called selective incorporation,
and it supposedly reserves more power to the states.
What it really means is that when people
felt that the states were violating their liberties,
they had to go to the Supreme Court, which by now
has incorporated almost every clause in the Bill of Rights against the states.
You want examples? We've got them. In the
famous case of Gitlow vs. New York, the court
ruled that the first amendment protection
of the freedom of speech could not be violated
by a state. In this case, it was New York,
but once a liberty is incorporated against
one state, it's incorporated against all of
them. In Mapp vs. Ohio, the court ruled that
states couldn't use evidence gathered from
warrantless searches. In Benton vs. Maryland,
the right against Double Jeopardy, being tried
for the same crime twice, was incorporated
against the states. By now, almost all the
rights and liberties mentioned in the first
ten Amendments have been incorporated against
the states. This means that individuals are
protected from all their governments taking
away their liberties, and that's a good thing.
I loves my liberties.
So we'll be talking about civil rights and
civil liberties for a number of episodes,
and this topic, while confusing, can be lots
of fun. We might play liberties bingo, or
civil rights kickball. I don't know what those
things are, but they sound like fun. The main
thing to remember is that going all the way
back to the framers, Americans have been concerned
about a too powerful government taking away
citizens' freedoms. Yes, these liberties apply
mostly to citizens, although some do apply
to non-citizens, too. In order to put limits
on government, the Bill of Rights was added
to the Constitution in 1789, but this didn't
mean that those limits applied to the states,
probably because the founders expected states
to be the main protectors of rights, and in
fact, many state constitutions have provisions
that copy or in some ways, go beyond what's
in the US Constitution. Only after the 14th
Amendment was passed, following the Civil
War, did the national government get around
to addressing this issue of states denying
people's liberties. Even then, it took numerous
court cases for us to get to the point that
most civil liberties that we assume cannot
be taken away by the government have actually
been guaranteed through the process of selective
incorporation. It's taken a long time to get
where we are, and there's still a long way
to go. Protecting civil liberties requires
vigilant citizens to be aware of the ways
that government is overstepping its bounds,
but that's only half the equation. It's also
vital that our majority pay attention the
civil rights of others, and that we ensure
that everyone is afforded the same protections
and benefits promised by our system of law.
Thanks for watching. I'll see you next time.
Crash Course Government and Politics is produced
in association with PBS Digital Studios. Support
for Crash Course US Government comes from
Voqal. Voqal supports non-profits that use
technology and media to advance social equity.
Learn more about their mission and initiatives
at Voqal.org. Crash Course is made with the
help of these nice people who are innocent
until proven guilty. Thanks for watching.